Hello everyone, this is Frank DeFratis and welcome to HoloTalk, the Internet's laser and holography talk show enjoyed in over forty two countries throughout the world.
And now here's this week's show.
Hello, Triple Take.
Hi Joy, how are you?
It's Frank.
Hi, how you doing?
Doing pretty good.
Good.
You're all set then, right?
Yep.
How are you?
I'm doing good.
You're probably doing better out there than you would out here with all the snowstorms we've gotten so far.
Yep, I was just talking to my sister out there and she was shoveling this morning.
I'm beat.
Yep.
I don't miss that part.
It's not even it's not even winter yet, it's still fall.
I know.
Yeah.
You don't usually get it until January.
Well, I'm glad you decided to come on the f uh on the on the show.
First I I would just want to explain to the listeners that I had promised to bring you on because I wanted to do something specifically with you for two areas.
Your your triple take holographics business that you have since we're in the holiday season now, full swing.
And also I believe you're involved with a number of different uh professional organizations.
I believe it's women in optics and things of that nature, right?
Right.
So we can talk a little bit about both of those.
How's that?
Okay.
Now you came into this starting triple takes.
You all right you already had a professional background in holography.
In fact, uh you weren't too far from me.
You were up in Elmsford, New York for a while, right?
That's right.
Wha what was your capacity up there with uh uh uh American banknote?
Um essentially I was the holographer, that's the title, and what it meant is that I was the person who took the artwork that was already uh developed from the art department, and I actually put it on the table and created the master hologram.
Okay.
And after that it was sent off to the production floor for the embossing.
Mm-hmm.
And you know, I was up at American Banknote holograph uh graphics up in the eighties.
I I guess you weren't there at the time.
Someone took me down into the studio.
Uh-huh.
Was Denish there as well?
Uh he would have been coming along I think in eighty six.
So it might have been still earlier than that.
Yeah I w I wonder if he was the one that took me down.
Um it was most likely uh Lenny I think's been there for a long time and he's the the lab manager.
Was it w who was the one that did the um Michael Jordan cover for Sports Illustrated.
Oh, that would have been Todd.
Okay, 'cause I he he actually visited here one time.
Okay.
I had him autograph one of the uh c one of the Sports Illustrated covers.
Yeah, so did I.
Did you?
Yeah.
The best time holographers signed their work.
So y you're probably doing what is the most difficult job to do in holography today and a and that is running a small business.
Absolutely.
What are what are some of the products the two of you put together and you might want to just go over quickly both of your roles and responsibilities w within the uh the business that you have.
Um well as far as the the products that we're producing, we can in fact make almost any kind of hologram.
Um we have the capability and the knowledge to do so.
Um what you'll find on our website is primarily the DCG which I have uh partnered in with a lot of art glass in order to create uh products that that are more saleable because people would I mean people will buy a coaster anyway but what they look for is the decorative aspect of the coaster.
And so if you put a hologram on it, it's not a super high art thing, but it's interesting the decor thing that we have a lot of people interested in.
So that's what kind of stuff we make.
Clocks, coasters, keychains, you know, the usual uh assortment of products.
Now these items that you create, they're not there's no automation involved in this process at all.
They're all made by hand, is that correct?
Yeah.
They're all handmade by our own two little fingers.
Um as far as the well, actually I guess twenty fingers.
The uh actual holography starts with um most of the time the actual image is inspired by someone who wants something.
Um then I'll put together some kind of a model or artwork.
Uh we set it up on the table.
Dinesh loves to do the chemistry part, so I like to do the geometry part, which works out really well for the two of us.
I go in and set up the table, and then he shoots the holograms and develops them and comes up with all of those um kinds of uh parameters.
And then we seal it um into the glass, and then I go into the back and shape it into whatever shape it's gonna be into, whether it be coaster or actually I can do some very uh elaborate things.
Sometimes I put the the gold gilding edge or you know, it depends on what we want to do with it.
Now where would someone find your products other than the website?
Or are there um commercial outlets that uh retailers that are stocking anything?
Um I don't have any commercial outlets, but we have worked with other people who have had us make something for them that they have sold again on the private market.
Um we've made some things for Ray Bell.
Um there's um a couple of internal things we've done for um the Navy has had um various at uh things that they do, they um like the the ball or something.
They'll have this big gala event and then we made the gifts that were handed out to the guests there.
Yeah.
Um, that sort of thing.
So it's largely internal.
One of the things when I said, you know, about figuring out a business is it's it's even harder it's hard enough to make to make the product, harder to make a business and even harder that still to figure out what the public is going to want.
Mm-hmm.
So most of what we've done is to have the public come to us and say this is what we want and then we go make it.
Yeah.
I imagine the majority of people that are going to be listening to the show would be people who are already doing holograms to begin with.
That's although there is a a pretty large cross section of of people who listen to the show, such as educators, students and things of that nature.
Um on a scale of one to ten, uh uh how difficult is it day by day?
I mean, the mu the the hours must be long and and and the work must be grueling sometimes.
Um it depends.
I mean, as you said, especially since most of these guys are making holograms themselves, you realize that, you know, if you love what you're doing, you don't count the hours.
Mm-hmm.
Um I do.
Well to some extent.
I mean, because we're trying to make a business, the more important thing is counting the money.
At least today I would.
Yeah.
Well, today's a snowy day for you, so you'd want to stay in.
I'd probably be shooting today if I were at home.
Some of my some of my brightest holograms have happened when I've shot them on the nights of snowstorms.
Yep.
'Cause I live in center city and it actually dampens the entire geographical area.
Yeah, I bet it would.
That'd be nice.
So a relatively stable area here because most of the underlayment is granite.
I see.
You were our table does float if we need really long exposures.
Oh, so one of those nice Newport tables.
Oh, that's nice.
That's nice.
Actually I understand there's a few hands that have had us before because it has a a strange feature in the middle of it, a cutout.
And other people coming in here have looked at that and said, I've seen that table somewhere before.
Huh.
D do you work in your home?
No.
Um we have a whole separate studio.
Oh do you?
It's about four thousand square feet.
Decent really decent size.
Um it is actually the studio that Don Broadbent was in.
Okay.
We met up with him um I guess about seven years ago is as long as we've been in San Diego.
And he was um someone we'd never met before.
We'd heard through other people that he was selling off equipment because he wanted to retire.
So we met up with him and we actually um got him uh a brief uh job at the place where we were working with which was a photonics company at the time.
And so we sort of started getting together and then we started thinking that we'd love to make our own business on the side so we actually kind of moved in with Don here at this studio with the idea that we were going to do like a transition thing until he retired um because he was going to be moving away.
And so we eventually did that and in two thousand February two thousand we took over entirely and became Triple Takes.
I see.
And Don is still lurking out there.
Um I believe he's in Arizona now.
So if anybody's trying to get in touch with him I know how to find him.
Well that that truly is a business that that you're running there.
Do you have a display area that folks could come in and see holograms?
Um, there's a small display area.
We have a private collection, um, because I like to collect other holographers' work as well.
So some of the things are actually at home.
Um, but we do have a display area here.
Um mostly our product um but also a few other pieces that um we've collected along the way that are from other holographers that have actually come into the studio or students that have worked here.
Um couple of my favorite pieces from people that are a little more friends than you know, we have uh uh Bobman from Richmond Studios.
Mm-hmm that uh was one of my favorites long before I ever knew where it came from.
And when Edwina finally gave me a copy of it, that was one of my treasured pieces and I have it up here at the lab as well.
Did you say Linda Man?
Yes.
Yeah.
There's there's someone down by Philadelphia that actually is it on film or is it on glass plate?
It's on film, yeah.
Um and I framed it in a regular glass frame.
Yeah, there's there's there's someone down in Philadelphia in uh in New Hope, Pennsylvania that uh has one on display in a shop down there that's an actual glass plate.
Is that the three D shop out in the Amish village?
Uh n no n no, you're probably thinking more towards Lancaster.
This this is more towards the Delaware River down by Philadelphia.
It's a small town called New Hope.
Yeah.
Well I know the area.
I have cousins there.
It's name's uh yeah, Howard Kerr's is his name.
I think it's Laser Illusions or something is the uh is the shop.
But it's it's one of the shops that he he has a wonderful collection of holograms there, and a lot of them were on glass plates.
Uh but in order to stay afloat, you know, with some of those shops you have to have a lot of different novelty items as well.
Right.
You know, along with it.
So it's uh it's uh a mix of a lot of different things there.
Mm-hmm.
And we've been getting a lot of calls from people that said that have been saying that you know, I used to be able to get stickers and I used to be able to get this and everything, where do you get it anymore?
And so there's definitely a lot of room out there for that kind of thing because you know, there are people out there that want it and don't know where to go anymore.
Because even when I started up in holography, seriously, I mean when I actually got my first job in it, already, you know, all of the schools were closed, all of the galleries were closed.
You know, there was just this big black hole.
Yeah, yeah.
In holography.
And I think right now, especially with the internet and and these sorts of things getting out there, there's more and peop more and more people getting involved.
And there's more people who know what it is.
Yeah.
So you know, if we can just get the the public a little more involved again, you know, there might be a resurgence.
There may be, yeah.
Or we may see it, you know, the technology just you know, it's it's a it's a competing technology and there are a lot of technologies competing with it, so uh I was down at the uh you you know where Camden, New Jersey is, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I was down at the uh new aquarium, you know, they closed the state aquarium, I think a private uh venture took it over.
Uhhuh.
And they put in a new uh three D theater.
So I had the opportunity of seeing my first three D film uh shot underwater.
And oh I I I I I was expecting to go in there to see something uh rather crass, you know, as far as uh technology is concerned and effect.
Uhhuh.
But it was gorgeous.
I mean it was just absolutely it was like you were engulfed in in uh in the actual movie itself.
It was Yeah, I love those new theaters.
They're they're mostly they're put out by IMAX, but it's a completely different design than the old IMAX domes.
They know used to be planetariums.
And the effect is fabulous.
Yeah.
I think with polarization was involved with the uh left left and right view and things like that.
Four D, huh?
We laugh about that because there was yeah, there was motion in the seats.
Uh-huh.
And you would get sprayed with water as well.
That's right.
So I guess, you know It's great.
If anybody, you know, can get near one of these, you know.
I think there's one in Harrisburg also, but I haven't actually been there.
That can run these three D uh Polaroid type uh displays and it's worth it.
Yeah.
You gotta go to these places.
Just just only any cheap Philly hot dogs before you go in.
You know.
You also mentioned workshops.
Maybe uh do do you run workshops that uh Um people can come to working with the local Palomar College.
Okay.
And so what they do is that they're the ones who organize and do all the advertising to get the students in and then we run the workshops.
Mm-hmm.
And that's been really a lot of fun.
Uh we can only take about three or four students at a time in the lab, obviously, because we've only got so much working room.
Um, but we've gotten some good response and the people that have come have just been thrilled that they've never done such a thing before as making a hologram and and of course we love teaching.
Yeah.
I started doing the workshops here in eighty three.
Mhm.
And from I'd say el late elementary, middle school kids all the way up into uh retirees.
Uhhuh.
Yeah.
In fact, actually I think most of our our students have been older.
Um there was only one younger kid and even that wasn't, you know, a kid.
He was I think twenty five.
Yeah.
Um so that's you know, I think that speaks also about the the form or glory of holography is that the people who understand what it really is and really have always wanted to do that is the older generation and I'd like to really reach out to the younger generation and get them more involved in recognizing what the medium can do.
And not just, you know, peachy little stickers, you know, for their notebooks.
Mm-hmm.
Well I used to run the uh laser and holography workshops at a place in Philadelphia called the Franklin Institute.
Uhhuh.
So I was down there for about ten years and that was a gifted and talented program that would come in there for workshops and they were all all young students that would come in for that.
Uh-huh.
And um oh Jesus is going back a long, long time.
See maybe I could have been one of those students.
I well I'll tell you what, I recently just had one of the students come back with one of their own children.
Uh-huh.
So I'm sort of like a grand teacher.
Yeah.
You know, like that feel great.
Yeah, it's it was a wonderful I I I to t to to be honest with you, I I can't remember the person, you know, I mean they're grown and they say you know they're in a workshop but you can't remember who they are really I mean 'cause it's it's not like you have them for a year or two years.
You have them for two or three hours on a Sunday afternoon and then you never see them again, you know, twenty years ago or whatever.
But it's it is a nice feeling at the being in the second generation of it now.
Mhm.
In addition to uh running our normal workshops with the the college, we also have done some professional lectures for uh for companies that are working in photonics, um for the the colleges themselves in their colloquia and and things like that.
So we you know that's feeding up into the the higher consulting that we're also doing.
You always have to keep an eye out when you have your own business for other work.
Oh, of course.
It's a very delicate process.
I'd say maybe I think in nineteen ninety three I went on my own entirely with holography.
And um that was probably an early mistake that I made was that uh while you're doing the work, you not only have to do the work, but you constantly have to be looking for work that's further on down the line.
Yes.
Because once all of the work that you finally you know that you have is complete, all of a sudden you hit a wall because you haven't been looking for other work to come in and it's uh it's a very difficult uh balance to maintain.
Yeah.
And both jobs can be full time.
Absolutely.
Yes.
Yeah, if you're working in March, you've gotta be wor you've gotta be uh arranging things for July, you know.
That's right.
Yeah.
What's your involvement with women in optics?
I saw a picture on your website of a group uh that got together, I guess it must be that it must have been a dinner in New York or something.
It was actually at SBIE.
Um at all of the different um optics conventions they do have a little luncheon where they get together.
And the primary function really of the women in optics is to support women doing research specifically that we can help fund their way to uh giving a lecture at one of these conferences.
And that's really the the primary function is just to to give women the opportunity to step up in the in the optics world and present themselves and become, you know, better known and better established professionals.
I imagine you also have outreach educational outreach programs available for high school students as well, or no?
I know I don't actually know that much because I'm not one of the organizers.
Um I'm just sort of one of the members and I showed up at the luncheons and that sort of thing, but I haven't really gotten terribly involved.
Yeah in the deeper stuff.
When women in optics got started I had someone on from SPIE and I I am I have to apologize but I cannot remember the name right now in the state I'm in.
But uh I think we had I I had a number of downloads that they could download educational packets too, you know, about the organization.
I think they're they're probably back in the archives of the show somewhere and the show goes back I think it's going in its ninth year now.
So uh it's been a while.
Yep.
Well I'm sure that I I don't actually if you go through the SBIU website you can probably find their link.
Yeah.
I don't know that off the top of my head either.
How about some information?
I'll put a link to your website on the page on the web page.
Okay, thank you.
And uh I don't know what that's going to do.
Don't uh don't expect a rush or anything like that of uh orders or anything but especially considering the audience that it's going out to I guess people you know that are listening to this are basically just in interested in hearing about triple take and what you do and things of that nature.
But uh I'd like to begin promoting what I call handcrafted holography.
These are folks that are working the same as a cabinet maker works or someone who hand makes a bicycle frame.
Uh-huh and they work in their own private labs in their own studios and they offer holograms for sale.
And I think that's basically what you're doing.
You f you you and Dinesh fall under that handcrafted holography category.
You have no no automation.
Yeah.
Well most of holography doesn't really um the industry hasn't grown big enough to support people who make automation equipment.
You know, there there's a lot of people that have made their own for their own purposes but have then tried to go off and sell it to other people.
There are a couple of those companies around.
Um but it really is you know all hand done.
Um apart from you've got the like the dot matrix machines and everything.
But that mostly is you know not really artistic enough for the people who want to do this kind of thing.
They want to do the whole three dimensional you know coming out edge kind of stuff.
Yeah.
Uh speaking of dot matrix and and things of that nature, do you do any mastering for embossed telography at all?
Um yes we do.
Um we don't have the ability at present to print our to do the actual embossing.
But we have made masters and then send them out and one of the things that we're looking at for next year is you know to see if we can get some in house equipment because one of the other things that a lot of people seem interested in is you know they they don't want five million pieces to go to American bank note to have it done.
You know, they want something a little more personalized and so you know we'd like to look into doing some more embossed work in the next year.
Yeah, for for short runs.
Yep.
Is that correct?
Yes.
Yeah, yeah.
Is there since we're coming up on twenty minutes already that's why I usually say f fifteen to twenty minutes because usually by the time the show's over it's thirty.
Uh-huh.
I try to keep the file sizes small, you know, 'cause with everything on the web anymore, you know, there's a lot of listeners that are over in Europe and Asia, believe it or not.
There's a there's a school a school, a girls' school, a science school in China that listens to the th it's a it's a girls' school.
Oh good.
I mean it's all over the place.
And uh but I the thing is the the longer the show, I'd love to do long shows, but the longer the show, the bigger the file size, and it's uh it's incredible to download this stuff anymore.
Yep.
Is there anything that you'd like to mention that I did not ask about?
Um, let me think about what we've gone through, my goodness, just about everything.
What would your advice be to students that would be out there that might be or anyone for that matter that might be thinking about doing holography as a business because you probably get emails all the time.
I get emails all the time with you know, people that have ideas for the next big thing.
And uh what would you say to someone?
Yeah, I would think that if you're trying to make a business of it, you have to get outside of yourself because when you're doing a business of any kind, even if you're providing a product, you're still really providing a service.
And one of the things that holographers frequently do is they're so enamored of their own technology that they don't recognize how other people see it.
Mm-hmm.
That's an excellent ver that's an excellent point.
And one of the things when I my the very first holographer that I met face to face was actually Dan Schweitzer.
Um, then the production holographers at ABN, of course.
And he really was a big inspiration to me because what I saw him doing was stepping outside of just the medium and seeing what you can do with it.
He liked to play with the images floating in space, and he took little little steel models and and interacted with them.
And he really was looking to see what he could pull out of it.
And not just what can I do with it.
And I think that was really something that I've carried with me along the way, and I hope I can live up to that.
I think Dan had a background in theater, didn't he?
Stage stage work or something.
Because but you can see it in his work.
Yeah.
I'm not sure if that's correct or not.
I s I spoke with Dan a number of different times and for some reason that uh that sticks with me.
Mm-hmm.
Dan Dan was going to do a whole of talk interviewing me before he passed away.
Oh.
And we never we never got around to doing that and I never saw it any I never sought out anyone else to do it since then.
Because Dan was the guy that uh that was going to do it.
Sounds like a good idea.
That show may never air.
So we were we we grew did we grow up close to one another I was from Philly.
Yeah.
Um I actually grew up in Cherry Hill, New Jersey.
Get out of here.
My wife's from Belmore.
Yeah.
In fact I'm probably going to see my mom for Christmas.
No kidding.
He still lives there.
Hm.
But Cherry Hill when I first went out looking for holographers and I made some phone calls and I don't know if you might have been actually one of the people I called when I came out of college.
Um looking for job.
Oh was told that there are no jobs.
We're all independent people working out of our basements.
Yeah.
Huh.
That w that would have been something I would have said.
In a nice way of course.
Yeah.
But you did tell me some of the other things that were going on in holography and not just art but also in technical holography and I think that inspired me as well because I did that one foot in the technical world.
Oh.
Or it might have been you.
It might have been I don't remember who it was.
Yeah.
I know that I learned originally um I had gotten a book from a friend of mine when I was a kid.
It was uh Jeff Berner's holography book.
And in the back of it was a bunch of interviews with the old holographers.
Oh.
And so that's where I started and started calling people around that were local to me.
And I know I talked to Ken Dunkley.
And I know I talked to a second person and I can't remember who it was.
And it may well have been you.
May have been.
Yeah, Cherry Hill.
Do you ever go to Cherry Hill Mall?
All the time.
Yep.
Me too.
I have to work there a few times.
Did you?
Get out of here.
Yeah, I go my w my wife and I when we first started dating we're we're together thirty years this year.
And when we first started dating we went to a restaurant down at the airport circle called the pub.
Uh-huh.
And uh we always like to travel down there and have dinner down there and also stop uh like a Cherry Hill Mall and things like that.
So the mall the mall is still there.
Yes it is.
That's I think isn't that supposed to be one of the first malls on the east coast?
That's what I kept telling people and uh the one of the cornerstones it's in Storebridge and Clothy or right down there is where the fountains were.
I think it said like nineteen sixty one or something.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
Used to go over there when I was a kid.
They used to have uh summer concert series with uh with the uh Pop's Orchestra.
Uhhuh.
Right there by the fountains and we used to sit there and listen to all the uh show tunes and all stuff like that.
Yep.
Yeah.
It's a great place.
All right, Joy.
Anything else?
Um, no, I think that's good.
Now we're people will be liv listening to this probably twenty years from now, I guess.
That would be nice.
Yeah.
I don't know if I guess if the same people are still in the business twenty years from now.
But that'll be interesting.
We're we're in it for a long time.
Yes indeed.
Yeah.
Cheers.
All right.
Well, you have a very nice holiday.
You too.
Do you celebrate Christmas?
Yes I do.
With a Merry Christmas.
Merry Christmas to you.
And uh please tell Dinesh I say hello.
Okay.
And uh we'll have to get together sometime.
Yep.
All right.
We'll be up there probably and see if we can get some time in for you.
Okay.
I'll have to give a call.
All right.
You take care.
And thank you for being on the show and taking the time.
You're welcome.
Thank you for having me.
Thank you.
Bye.